[Music]
good morning
hey
it's great to see you all you look
fantastic
good job even with the masks on you
still look fantastic it's been a long
time
i hope you're really excited about the
day um
it's been i don't know for me fantastic
to have you all in person are you ready
are you ready
okay
stand up and go
good luck
i think my squad is a bunch of killers i
think they're going to absolutely
dominate i'm going to be honest i think
they did extremely well in the role
plays they've always taken them
seriously they've had no problem jumping
into character
and i think they're gonna do great it'd
be a great learning experience for them
to deal with people in like the real
world i think uncertainty is just
something to predict now so i don't know
whatever happens it'll it'll it'll work
out well i think the aha moment that i
always get at the gsp is how smart the
students are
you know the students are very smart i
mean so they were given the case
just
an hour before we met
and they already had their facts all
lined up
they already had their reasoning and
their preferred choice
and arguments pros and cons you know we
spent a lot of time thinking through
negotiation tactics and also working
together as a squad to think through who
has uh who has the right skills for
which situation not really sure what to
expect um also really looking forward to
meeting the alums um and seeing what
feedback they have we heard it for one
of the students was
we realized as we got to the end of this
interaction with the alums that a board
meeting is not about presenting to the
board it's about engaging with the board
they're going to do great they've been
practicing for this not only all this
quarter all their life and i was
calculating that if on average each
judge had about 20 years of experience
there's like over a century of
experience in that room and so
as tony robbins says if you can just
take that experience of say a hundred
years and learn it all in one afternoon
well think of how much time you saved i
think just really this kind of being a
nice culminating experience with my
squad especially after our last session
was really focused on feedback i'm
feeling
fantastic it's really exciting to see
all of our squad and the folks who are
coming in first year at the gsb
culminating today it's going to be a
great experience
i just feel like i took away maybe more
than they even did
we have a great spot i'm very confident
that we're going to crush it
i would say our biggest thing is that
feedback is a gift and we've been really
practicing being open and frank about
feedback and providing constructive
feedback so i think
being able to learn
and improve over the course of the
leadership labs activity has been really
rewarding and i'm excited to see how my
team will improve over the course of the
challenge i am excited i'm nervous um
don't really know what to expect but it
should be a good time
my role for there i'm about to find out
uh but being myself a true leader i'm
feeling good feeling energized i'm
waiting for that coffee to open up but
pretty excited for the day i feel like
our squad has worked a lot together to
really do
kind of hone in on our leadership skills
and so i'm curious to see how it all
pans out i never had to have these kind
discussions before
so this
man this
this is a great experience that you guys
are exposing
first quarter nba ones too
well i think it's going to be a cool day
with some cool people i'm excited to
meet the judges and to hopefully have a
cool executive challenge and learn
something to
actually try different approaches
different uh takes in a lab environment
right it's not in real life so if they
succeed they learn what works if they
fail fail beautifully they feel in a
very safe environment i'm excited to
hang out with my squad
they're awesome
i'm excited to be on tv
hi mom
17 again
[Applause]
we're team 18 we're team 18.
okay
no someone else had something
[Music]
we actually bought champagne i had a
shipment from napa that arrived
yesterday so we're gonna celebrate
really well
[Music]
you